WandaVision is one hell of a weird show and
whether you love it or are just plain confused,
you'll want to know how it connects with the
rest of the MCU.
And like any great mystery, there are a ton
of clues that reveal the show's connections
to the Avengers, Spider-Man and even the X-Men.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining the weirdest and
most perplexing scenes, theories, MCU references
and easter eggs in WandaVision.
Plus I'll explain the new Phase 4 villains
like Mephisto and Grim Reaper that we can
expect to see in the show.
Spoilers and speculation ahead, of course!
Set in Westview, WandaVision takes places
in a strange new sitcom reality that Wanda
appears to have created for herself.
A clue that Wanda and Vision are living inside
their own bubble reality or pocket dimension
is the curious design of Vision's tie with
two dots inside a rectangle with two more
dots on the outside.
And given the SWORD encampment that's been
set up in this wooded area and a strange energy
field nearby, it suggests that Wanda may have
taken over a town with her powers.
This would explain why the real world occasionally
seems to leak into Wanda's alternate reality,
such as when a voice on the radio calls out
to Wanda.
"Wanda.
Who's doing this to you Wanda?"
And when Dottie asks who she really is.
"Who are you?"
A similar moment happens when Mr Hart is choking
at the dinner table, and his wife tells him
over and over to "stop it", although this
instruction seems to be almost directed towards
Wanda instead.
"Stop it.
Stop it.
Stop it."
It's a very weird and creepy moment especially
as after Vision uses his phasing ability to
pull out the food, everyone seems to forget
that anything happened and they leave.
I think that Wanda may be using her reality-bending
or illusion-inducing powers that we saw her
use in Age of Ultron against the Avengers
to maintain the idealised world she's created
for herself in Westview.
It appears that characters can actually get
hurt though, such as when Dottie cuts her
hand and we can see the blood in actual colour.
By the way, the voice on the radio sounds
a lot like Randall Park, aka Jimmy Woo from
Ant-Man and the Wasp, who we know is now working
for SWORD in WandaVision.
SWORD is the acronym for the "Sentient Weapon
Observation and Response Division" and you
can see they're the ones monitoring Wanda
and Vision at the end of the first episode.
It also suggests that the agency views Wanda
and or Vision to be sentient weapons that
could pose a threat.
There's also a deep-cut easter egg in this
scene referencing the wider MCU multiverse,
when the fake credits for the WandaVision
show roll by and we see that the name of the
director is "Abe Brown", one of Peter Parker's
classmates.
Abe was a Spider-Man character who survived
the Snap, and this suggests that he's now
working for SWORD.
And it might even point to Wanda appearing
in the next MCU Spider-Man movie, given we
know that she's already in Doctor Strange
and the Multiverse of Madness
especially since Spider-Man 3 will be featuring
the Spider-Man multiverse with appearances
from Alfred Molina's Doc Oc and Jamie Foxx's
Electro.
There's evidently a lot more to Wanda's nosy
neighbour than she's letting on.
And given we see her dressed as a witch later
in the series, many fans are assuming she's
playing the comic book character Agatha Harkness,
a witch from Salem, especially as her name
Agness combines the first and last syllables
of "Agatha Harkness".
However, I think this may be almost too obvious
and Marvel is planning a little twist and
she turns out to be Mephisto, one of Phase
4's next big villains.
One of the clues is in how she reacts to Dottie
in this scene.
"The devil's in the details, Bev."
"That's not the only place he is."
And then she has a pet rabbit called "Señor
Scratchy" which is a big clue because "Mr
Scratch" is a nickname for the devil.
This might also be a reference to Agness's
son in the comics, Nicholas Scratch, a major
Fantastic Four supervillain.
Agness even draws attention to Scratch's importance
"Señor Scratchy just loves the stage.
He played baby Jesus in last year's Christmas
pageant."
For those unfamiliar, Mephisto is an extremely
powerful demonic villain who rules a pocket
dimension called Hell in the comics,
and who seems set to become an important villain
in the MCU given the prominent display of
a devil in a stained glass window in the Loki
trailer.
It's also interesting that Agness constantly
jokes in the show about her husband Ralph,
who we mysteriously haven't seen yet.
"The only way Ralph would remember our anniversary
is if there was a beer named June 2nd."
The name Ralph is significant because he's
a character from Christopher Marlowe's play
Doctor Faustus who helped conjure devils such
as Mephistopheles, who the Marvel villain
Mephisto is based on and named after.
Another mystery in the show is the identity
of the beekeeper who climbs out of a sewer
at the end of the second episode.
A clue from a new featurette shows that this
appears to be a SWORD agent being sent into
the pocket dimension that Wanda and Vision
are in,
as you can see him crawling through a tunnel
and then his hazmat suit changes into a beekeeper's
costume.
Why a beekeeper though?
Well, although it may be a reference to the
Marvel supervillain Swarm whose body is made
up of bees, bees themselves actually have
some specific symbolism that's very appropriate
to WandaVision.
As pollinators, they're frequently associated
with fertility and reproduction, and so link
to Wanda's pregnancy.
And in Celtic mythology, bees are regarded
as messengers between heaven and earth or
different realms
which is also fitting because the beekeeper's
arrival seems to be an attempt from the world
outside to make contact with Wanda.
Wanda either consciously or intuitively understands
this and when she sees him she says "No" and
rewinds time back to the moment when she asks
Vision if "this is really happening";
and this time rather than going outside, she
transforms their world into a now colour-filled
sitcom reality.
Wanda being able to rewind time here for a
do-over,
reminds me of how Vision died twice in Infinity
War when Thanos rewound time to undo Wanda's
destruction of the Mind Stone, so that he
could take the infinity stone for himself.
More on Wanda's time manipulation powers shortly.
The "No" that Wanda says to the Beekeeper
may also be a reference to Wanda's famous
line "No more mutants" from the "House of
'M'" storyline, in which Scarlet Witch caused
almost every mutant to lose their powers.
Marvel Studios might be looking to subvert
this iconic comic book moment by having Wanda
be the gateway to bringing mutants and the
X-Men into the MCU, so look out for her saying
"more mutants" later on in the series.
And there's another neat reference to the
"House of 'M'" via the wine served at Wanda's
dinner party.
The bottle's label reads "Maison du Mépris"
which translates to English as "House of Contempt",
plus there's a letter 'M' around the neck
of the bottle.
And WandaVision's credits are a cool visual
nod to the way her mental breakdown in the
comics is represented by her disintegrating
reality into blocks.
There are some especially creepy moments in
the second episode when the various residents
of Westview chant "For the children" together:
"For the children.
For the children.
For the children."
Then there's Mrs Hart who badgers Wanda and
Vision about why they don't have children
and the headline on the newspaper that Vision
reads says "Little Baby June's First Words
Tickle Mother Sue".
Agnes also seems to be very keen on getting
Wanda to seduce Vision in the first episode.
"What about seduction techniques?"
And Dottie is another mysterious character
intent on pushing the "For the children" agenda.
On top of that, it's particularly disturbing
that there aren't even any children around
in these scenes.
However, all of these pressures seem to have
worked into brainwashing the couple by the
end of episode two.
"And it was all for the children."
And just like that, as if by magic, Wanda
discovers she's pregnant, perhaps because
she simply decided it.
It feels like there's some strange presence
at work here, lurking in the background, such
as Mephisto, who could be looking to take
control of Wanda's children who will undoubtedly
be super-powered when they're born.
In the comics, when Wanda has children, she
discovers they're the outcome of her magic
mixing with fragments of Mephisto's soul.
Now, the MCU won't be following the comic
book storylines exactly, however, it often
takes elements and inspiration from them,
so it's quite likely that Mephisto has something
to do with Wanda's pregnancy and children.
It's also possible that Wanda made a bargain
with the devil to bring Vision back to life
and he'll later try to collect on the deal
by taking away her children.
Is that what the voice means when it asks
Wanda, "Who is doing this to you?"
The fake ad breaks also provide some more
clues as to what may be going on in Wanda's
mind and how she may be processing the various
traumas she's experienced in her life.
The watch commercial advertising Strucker
watches is, of course, a reference to Baron
von Strucker, the HYDRA leader who experimented
on Wanda and her brother Pietro with the Mind
Stone.
"Strücker.
He'll make time for you."
But this is more than just an easter egg for
Marvel fans, as I think it's implying that
Wanda may have inherited more powers than
we realise from the Mind Stone,
including the ability to manipulate and rewind
time, which she did after seeing the Beekeeper.
And there was another awesome HYDRA easter
egg, cleverly hidden on the wallpaper in Wanda's
home.
As she turns everything to colour, you can
see the Sokovian HYDRA Research Base where
Wanda and her brother were kept and which
the Avengers attacked at the beginning of
Age of Ultron.
Again, this is Wanda's way of processing this
particular trauma.
The ad for a ToastMate 2000 by Stark Industries
is another traumatic reference for Wanda because
remember that she had an intense hatred for
Stark after one of his bombs killed her parents.
And listen very carefully during the commercial
because the noise that the toaster makes is
the same sound effect that Iron Man's blaster
makes as it powers up.
And the uncomfortable look on the housewife's
face as she waits for the bread to toast may
be a nod to how Wanda and Pietro spent two
days staring at Stark's bomb waiting for it
go to go off.
"We wait for two days.
For Tony Stark to kill us."
The message at the end of the ad, "Forget
the past, this is your future!", seems to
indicate that Wanda is trying to suppress
her painful memories and traumas through this
new reality she's created.
If you're wondering where Monica Rambeau is
in WandaVision, well she's already appeared
on the show, but her character is currently
called Geraldine.
"I'm Wanda."
"I'm, uh...
Geraldine.
I actually don't know what I'm doing here."
The loud crash that Wanda and Vision hear
at night at the beginning of the second episode
is a SWORD helicopter that I think Monica
Rambeau was piloting but which crashed through
to Westview from the world outside.
And it's represented by the red toy helicopter
that Wanda picks up the next day with a SWORD
logo on it.
There's a clever reference to this in the
magic trick that Vision and Wanda perform
later that day when Geraldine is teleported
from behind the stage into the Cabinet of
Mysteries.
And by the way, a cool detail here on the
cabinet artwork is the Mind Stone which looks
like it could be exploding, referencing how
Wanda destroyed the Stone in Vision's forehead
in Infinity War.
Again this may be another way that Wanda is
processing another traumatic event from her
life.
I also think it's interesting that Vision
refers to himself as an illusion in this scene,
a possible bit of foreshadowing that this
version of Vision may not be who he seems
to be.
"Of course I did the trick right!
I'm Illusion!"
In fact, in a recent trailer, I noticed Wanda
and Vision are facing off against each other,
so could Vision himself even turn out to be
the villain of WandaVision?
He is dead after all in the real world, so
could this Vision actually be a villain like
Mephisto in disguise?
And as Illusion's magic assistant, Wanda is
called Glamour, perhaps hinting that a glamour
or spell has been cast on her or Vision to
hide whatever is really going on.
And this might be a stretch, but the way that
each episode ends with Wanda and Vision enclosed
in a hexagon might also be suggesting that
a hex has been put on her.
A hex being an evil spell that brings bad
luck and trouble.
On top of that, a hexagon is also six-sided,
a hint perhaps to the devil's number 666,
together with the fact that this radio is
strangely missing a six.
And, of course, honeycombs are also often
made up of hexagonal formations, a potential
reference to the mysterious bee keeper then.
A few other easter eggs you might have missed
which may be significant include the Grim
Reaper's helmet in the second episode's opening
credits.
The Grim Reaper is a Marvel comics villain
and is rumoured to be appearing in WandaVision.
Plus, there's a possible easter egg to Wonder
Man, Grim Reaper's brother, in the credits
here.
So, what do you think of WandaVision?
And what are your favourite theories about
the show?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below!
And if you enjoyed this, leave a-thumbs up,
I really appreciate it.
Tap left for my next Marvel video and my theory
about Black Widow's secret twist, or tap right
for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!